well i i'm wondering let me ask you a
semi-political question here because i
think this could really affect trump
the fact that there's no college
football because i think a lot of
people in this country are like well
trump you know
you can kill granny and you can tank the
economy
but you know what don't check away my
football if i can't paint my face like
it's halloween and get blackout drunk at
nine in the morning
in a parking lot and go watch 19 year
olds give each other brain damage
you have just lost my vote do you think
that's that actually could affect the
election
listen we have two people running for
president that are in their late 70s
i don't think it's the most dynamic
presidential election of my life
i'm not sure how we got here um
i think people in america there's a
referendum bill
and they're going to vote against the
sitting president
not necessarily for his challenger
i believe that to be true i believe
suburban housewives
have turned that's my guess um i don't
think football
would affect it nfl will go on it will
make it through
i mean again they're gonna have we're
gonna have a lot of players test
positive let's not freak out like
they're not promising us
in the nfl they're not promising us
nobody's gonna test positive
college football right now two
conferences out three in my guess is in
a week
they're all out yeah and baseball
if i go back to that for one minute i
mean they are flirting sometimes now
with canceling their season because
we've had teams that did get a lot of
players
sick the marlins i think and the
cardinals right
and then you know you have to go to
basically the you know next man
up and you know it's a lot of scrubs
playing but i i must
i hope they don't cancel the season for
any reason i think it would be terrible
for morale i think
i think somebody has to run the flag up
and say we're the can-do people
we played sports during world war ii you
know that during world war ii the
steelers in football i'm sure you know
this and the eagles
the two pennsylvania teams combined to
make one team
the steagles that's what they said
because there's an emergency on and
we're just gonna
get through it ted williams probably
would have hit 800 homers if he didn't
have to fight in two wars
we don't quit we keep playing don't you
think that's important
well bill if you really look at what's
worked here ufc
dana white aggressive renidin island
nascar
aggressive we're going for it golf early
no fans we're going for it the people
that have bulldozed through
social media fear-mongering
the people who have been steadfast in
their beliefs
those sports and those leagues of work
if you're going to sit around and worry
about what they say on twitter
you're in there's a there's a lot of
fear porn you're in big trouble
and so dana white nfl nfl
bill you know this those owners want a
season we're gonna have a season
what do you think speaking of twitter
what'd you think of popovich
greg popovich standing it's interesting
you know we went from
like for only a year ago i mean
almost nobody was kneeling i remember
when that
issue first came up and i said well
given the history of this country it
wouldn't be such a bad idea if everybody
in the stadium
all the fans kneeled too i mean and now
that's kind of what's happening
everybody's kneeling and greg pogba has
impeccable liberal credentials he
he just said look i just made the
decision at the moment
everyone was kneeling but they played
the anthem and i just felt like standing
and i thought
yeah you know what you can do both
things you can say black lives matter
and i love my country and how about just
you do you i'll do me we don't do all
the same thing at the same time all the
time
well your resume should matter okay
lebron james
did not put black lives matter on his
jersey he didn't give us an answer why
right he he has equity in this isn't it
nice
that your resume matters and you're not
judged in a singular
photo on social media right you know
billy i've never talked about this but
i've always had this feeling that
all sports asks something of us
baseball asks us no clock be patient
it'll take a while
football football asks us there's a
regulated level of violence
you have to be comfortable with some of
it and the nba with lebron james asks us
there are social causes in the black
community that we care about
and we'll wear a t-shirt or we may kneel
and that's okay i opt in on that now
i don't think we should be arrogant
let's not bite naive
kneeling doesn't land the same for
everybody
you're a talk show host i am you you say
something on the air
it lands completely different it's not
contextualized on social media and you
can't believe
what's happening with the clickbait
right so that kneeling to me
lands as police reform and social
justice
right not for everybody but it's okay
you know i think you may have talked
about this if we're demanding growth
from people you can't simultaneously
demand perfection
right drew brees was tone death
but that's okay because then then his
teammates
he discusses this and he goes okay i was
tone deaf that's what growth is bill
right it's making mistakes the ability
to make mistakes
too often now we want perfection and
growth and they can't coexist
right and as i've said many times you
can hate trump
you can't hate all the people who like
him it's just too many people
you know
you